how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU one of the most anticipated movies
upcoming for Marvel Studios is guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 originally the film
was supposed to already have been out
but due to the firing and then rehiring
of James Gunn and of course Cove at 19
we're not going to be getting guardians
of the galaxy until at least a couple of
years but today we have learned a little
bit about what to expect from the film
now Marvel Studios threw a little bit of
a curveball at us with Avengers infinity
war and then Avengers endgame of course
an Infinity Ward Gamora died she was
sacrificed by Thanos to obtain the soul
stone however in Avengers in game they
kind of brought her back in a way they
brought the 2014 Gamora to our main
Marvel Cinematic Universe timeline
however this is not nearly the same
Gamora as we know from guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 she doesn't really know
who's star-lord is she doesn't know
rocket Groot Drax or mantas so a lot of
us are wondering what exactly is
guardians 3 going to be about well
luckily for us Karen Gillan teased just
a little bit of her story plot from
guardians of volume 3 and we'll break it
all down in this video if you're new be
sure to subscribe to stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU and a big
congratulations to Elijah Smith for
being last week's Marvel Funko pop The
Hulk
giveaway email me and the email in my
about Me section and we'll get you your
prize this week's giveaway is going to
be a Deadpool a Funko pop giveaway so
all you have to do is subscribe but like
the video and leave a comment down below
to enter so karen gillan who of course
plays nebula during a galaxy khan web
panel talked about her character nebula
and what we can expect from her in the
future
and she said I was able to use a lot of
psychology essays on that character
because she's someone who has dealt with
abuse from her father from such a young
age not to make it too heavy but he
pitted the siblings against each other
she would be inferior and the scapegoat
while the other one was the golden child
it's actually a quite common thing to
happen within families and siblings I
don't have any siblings so it's
something I really had to read up on but
she went on to say that she admires
nebula for her ability to slightly move
past that a little bit so when guardians
three were going to see kind of a
different nebula
moving past that and she goes on to say
in Avengers she had to face the source
of her abuse then actually watch him get
eliminated from her life I'm sort of
thinking about future Nebula in the
sense like what is she going to be like
now that that person's abuse has gone
out of her life how is she going to
build herself back up again because it's
an odd feeling I think for someone who's
been abused by a parent because they
still love them and they're sad that
they're gone but also they hate them and
they're glad that they're gone Karen
Gillan went on to say that nebula has
just had a really hard time of it and
that she's interested to maybe try and
take her to a place now where she's
starting to rebuild her life so
according to Karen Gillan as far as
nebula is concerned and guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 she's going to start to
rebuild her life and her rebuilding her
life will most likely start with a
search for her sister when we left the
guardians at the end of Avengers endgame
Thor was on board the ship with them and
star-lord was searching for Gamora zoe
saldana is confirmed to be in Guardians
3 so we know that eventually they're
going to have to run into her and nebula
and her bond is kind of going to have to
start over none of the things happen to
2014 Gamora that happened with the
present time Gamora who was currently
dead that brought her and nebula close
to each other so nebula is going to
start to rebuild her life and Guardians
3 and most likely star-lord is going to
have to do that as well since Gamora
doesn't really know who he is so it kind
of sounds like the guardians are going
to be in a bit of a rebuilding phase
while at the same time it's been rumored
that one of the guardians might actually
meet their death in guardians three
widely believed to be Rocket Raccoon but
we'll have to wait and see but as far as
nebula is concerned and most of the
guardians are concerned this is going to
be a rebuilding period for them nebula
more than ever will value the Guardians
as her new family since her sister and
father are gone and nebula was really
sort of a main character of avengers
endgame she had a very big story arc and
it sounds like she's going to have a big
story arc in guardians 3 as well so let
me know what you think about this what
do you think nebula is going to do now
that she doesn't have her father to
worry about and now that Gamora is kind
of gone let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like this video and subscribe but
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU as Oh
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof